this new Walking Dead game looks so bad
and it was published by the same people
as Gollum and the King Kong game who I
am going to have to interview for this
channel because what is going on here so
The Walking Dead Destinies is the name
of this new game that maybe I'll stream
at some point and here's a little what
it looks like this is from Gman lives on
Twitter
jackpot doesn't look that bad at first
tolerable and then you
just watch any of the
animations
What What In the dialogue is happening
you just got like Body slamed by a bunch
of zombies it's so chaotic and so
ridiculous but there's more why don't we
see what a cinematic looks like hey you
ought to be more polite to a man with a
gun huh onlyon sense not great voice
acting even you not terrible um very
noticeable that the models don't move
Tak orders from you I don't think so wow